I'm Gosia Trynka
I work as a group leader at the Sanger Institute in Cambridge.
My group is interested in understanding how
genetic variants modulate the immune system and in particular how they make the immune system
attack your own body, so that leads to
the autoimmune diseases
such as Type 1 diabetes or coeliac disease - gluten intolerance.
I have a wet lab background, that's what I did
during my Master's studies
and then I went through my PhD and I was
slowly understanding that I really
liked the computational part of the research.
So for my next step for
my post doc I decided to make it
really purely computational so I spent
two years developing statistical methods
but at that point also I realised
that I was actually missing
the wet lab component of it and that's
really what brings me here
and to my group where we have both the
wet lab and the dry lab
component really integrated that means
that we can
have research questions and address them
by generating our own data and
then analysing it ourselves.
In the wet lab we're trying to
understand
how the immune cells function and so for
that
we're isolating specific immune cell
types and then we're stimulating them to
see how they respond.
And then in order to measure that
respose on the molecular level
we perform different genomic assays and
the output of those assays
so the data that we generate in the wet lab
is then analysed in the dry lab.
Alot of the computational work really
involves getting rid of the
background noise from the data, the
experimental noise,
and fishing out that biological signal
that is important to us
and focusing on that. I always get really
very excited when the Natalia comes in
with some results and I want to know how
she did it?
What did she change? What things are
working? What things are not working?
How are we going to change them?
It's the process itself and then the
satisfaction when you get something
to work.
It's definitely one of the best parts
about being a scientist,
this moment when you go, yes it worked!
Or yes I found out
something new
It's amazing.
I've never had a master
plan, I never aimed to be here,
I always followed my passion, my interest
and the science that made me excited.
I never planned to do a PhD or become a
geneticist
so I don't know where I'm gonna be in
the future
but I'm also not worried about that
because I'm just going to keep on following
the research that makes me really excited.